Game of Thrones season 6 episode 8 let's
have a look we begin in Braavos where
lady crane performs that play again
she's taken I his advice and added a bit
in a speech about wanting vengeance she
heads backstage finds a wounded aya and
takes her home to heal her up which is a
big deal for aya you got to remember
that her life these last few years has
been one horror after another losing her
family imprisonment at Harrenhal roaming
the Riverlands joining a death cult so
this situation of comfort and trust and
normalcy is a really special moment a
rare chance to rest and heal though the
books emphasize that I may have hurt
that will not heal in the books she says
she feels a hole inside her where her
heart had been that the hole will never
feel any better after all that she's
been through aya is traumatized deeply
damaged which makes you wonder how her
story could possibly end like after all
the Fighting's done one way or another
she will hardly marry some Lord and
settle down as the noble lady she never
wanted to be in the first place will she
so it's interesting that in this scene
she talks about travelling west of
Westeros seeing the edge of the world
maybe that's how her story could end
maybe she could say her farewells get on
a boat and sail west into the sunset
like Frodo in Lord of the Rings passing
on to a place of rest somewhere between
heaven and death that could be beautiful
that said the iron revelations this
episode are pretty dumb it turns out
that is stabbing wasn't a trick wasn't
part of a plan that wasn't a twist is
seriously decided to go for a haircut
and have a nice afternoon stroll unarmed
not paying attention when she knew a
deadly assassin was hunting her as she
learned nothing from her training these
last season's and her stabbing looked
like it had kill her but all it takes is
a band-aid from crane and she's okay
this makes the stabbing feel like a
cheap trick on the audience a shock to
spark the clickbait Game of Thrones is
meant to be a show where if you [ __ ] up
there are lasting consequences so having
I you get us off stabbed from our own
carelessness then conveniently healed in
the next episode on the mines the brutal
realism that separates Thrones from
other fantasy shows every time a
character gets stabbed then it comes
back the same as they were before we
care less next time a Carrick
disturbed and that's happened like what
three times this season already
so that's lame but the episode does get
better because this time aya has a plan
some are in the Riverlands a bunch of
brotherhood dudes a talking [ __ ] when
hound comes along and murders them all
with an axe to avenge the death of
brother ray and his community who were
slaughtered last episode but with these
guys even guilty like the older two were
in the group that threatened Ray's
village so presumably they were involved
in the massacre but the younger guys
we've never seen before they seem to be
just a couple of naive young men so
unless the Hound knows something we
don't
he just murdered innocent people didn't
he a we meant to cheer for this maybe
this is where the character of the Hound
is going he's becoming more of an
antihero than a hero more a Punisher
than Superman someone who's willing to
do terrible things in the name of
justice which could be interesting but
it's striking how opposite this is to
what happens to the Hound in the books
where he joins a sort of a monastery to
atone for his sins he begins a life of
peace these chapters in the books are
about showing an alternative to violence
and conflicts showing that peace can be
possible the representative of this in
the show is brother ray but he and his
whole community are wiped out in the
same episode they're introduced which
sends the opposite message it suggests
that peace and pacifism will just get
you killed
that the only way to survive is to
perpetuate this endless cycle of
violence and vengeance and suffering if
that's the version of Westeros the show
wants to show then so be it but it does
feel wrong to see George Martin's in
many ways anti-war story turned into a
show that sometimes celebrates
indiscriminate violence Varys interion
chat about the status of marine which
seems to be improving since Tyrians
peace deal we see a red priestess
preaching about De Niro swing that
chosen one of the Lord of Light called
azor Ahai or the prince that was
promised which could get awkward when
Danny gets to Westeros because there the
red priest Melisandre thinks Jon Snow is
Azure a high you can't have two chosen
ones this could be a problem
anyway Varys is going back to Westeros
probably to kill those guys from the end
of book five and he and Tyrion say a sad
farewell they seem to have a real
friendship here which is sweet you can
see why they'd feel a connection they've
got a lot in common they're both very
clever
evil dudes who feel outcasts from
society Tyrion for being a dwarf and
varus for being a eunuch they're fond of
each other in the books too but book
varus isn't truly Tyrians friend in the
books varus manipulates Tyrion
manipulates everyone he has this huge
complex conspiracy going on with his fat
friend Illyrio with totally different
goals than the virus of the show his
character is much more extreme and
complex which is cool but it's also
kinda nice to see the show version of
varus being much more able to have
actual genuine relationships it's like a
more human version of the spider we know
from the books in King's Landing the
sparrows led by Lance all try to seize
Cersei it's still crazy to see how
different Lancel is from how he started
he used to be this meek incompetent kid
of fuck-buddy for Cersei and now he's in
a religious militia and she's an enemy
of the faith [ __ ] changed but anyway
Cersei chooses violence she sends in the
mountain who goes full Darth Vader on a
sparrow kybun looks on like a proud
soccer mom so pleased to see his
creation growing strong
Cobbins another really interesting
character when so she first meets him
he's described as looking like some
little girl's favorite grandfather a
soft-spoken man with warm brown eyes he
does not look like a monster we do hear
rumors that he does black magic that he
was kicked out of the Citadel for
performing experiments on living men but
it's only when Qyburn turns the dying
mountain to the monster he is now
through some mysterious process
involving screaming and pain and the
deaths of innocent women that we realize
that this sweet old man in some Yosef
Mengele [ __ ]
bad guys don't always look like bad guys
in this story Brienne and pod arrive at
Riverrun
while Brienne chats with Jaime Braun
choke spot for the banter they chat for
a while and bran teaches pod to fight
dirty which you could totally see coming
in handy later on maybe pod could save
Brienne by kicking a bolton in the nuts
or something but meanwhile Brienne and
Jaime talk and Jaime plays a kind of
cold at first acting dismissive of
Brienne but he does reaffirm his gift of
Oathkeeper that Valyrian steel sword
which is an incredibly valuable gift
remember there's just like a dozen of
those swords known left in the world but
it's also a very symbolic gift
representing Jaime's faith in and
respect for Brienne
that might be at the heart of Jaime and
Brienne s relationship because they both
crave respect but don't get it from the
outside world Brienne is a woman trying
to be a knight Jaime's the Kingslayer an
Oathbreaker so they both looked down on
by everyone but through their shared
suffering Jaime and Brienne come to see
the goodness and the strength and the
honor in each other even if no one else
does and that's why it's so tragic that
are stuck on opposite sides Jaime serves
King Tommen and the Lannisters while
Brienne serves Sansa Stark is an enemy
of the crown there is a bit of a star
crossed lovers vibe here but whether
Brienne and Jaime love each other
romantically or just as friends might
not be the point they give each other
the respect that they both so
desperately crave so Brienne heads into
Riverrun and tries to convince the
blackfish to give up the castle and come
helps answer and the Starks take
Winterfell which the book version of
blackfish probably would have done
because the main reason he holds
Riverrun is for his loyalty to the
Starks but sho blackfish mostly just
want to defend his family home so he
refuses Brienne and stays inside the
castle in King's Landing Cersei comes to
the Great Hall for an announcement and
she wants to stand by her son Tommen but
she's rejected by her son by her uncle
Kevan and by the ladies of court she
feels an outcast right now then King
Tommen gives his announcement he says
that trials by combat are now banned
because they're barbaric and unfair
which is pretty true it's silly that
having a powerful warrior on your side
can excuse you for crimes but the real
meat here is that now Cersei can't use
the mountain to win her trial and her
innocence so this looks to be another
clever play by the high Sparrow he's
outsmarted Cersei again but what this
also seems to mean is that we won't get
Clegane both a big theoretical fight
between gregor and Sandor that fans have
been hyped for for years which in some
ways is unsurprising the theory always
was pretty light on evidence and
thematic resonance but still why would
the show hype this fight if it's not
going to happen
Jaime says that is one trial by combat I
look forward to watching so while we
might not get clogged on ball in the way
it was imagined we might hopefully get
something like it anyway so Cersei has
her whole plan ruined she's now all out
of options which means she might be
about to do something really drastic
something fiery because at the end of
the same carbon
circe he looked into a rumor and found
something big and there are lots of
hints of what this might be
remember the wildfire the Napalm ii
green stuff that bran saw buried beneath
King's Landing that King Aerys once used
to try to burn down the city remember
all those times so she said she'd burn
cities to the ground I will burn our
house to the ground I will burn their
cities to the ground I'd burn cities to
the cities - remember that vision in
season 2 of King's Landing looking like
it had been burned there's lots of
evidence in the show and the books that
Cersei will try to use wildfire to burn
down King's Landing in an act of Mad
revenge and fury against everyone who
wronged her the only thing left that
might stop her from doing all this is
her son Tommen who she still loves above
all else so maybe he'll need to die
somehow to spark Sosa's rage and grief
in the books there is the valonqar
prophecy which are just assumed that
Jaime might kill Cersei to save the city
a second time and the shot of a dragon
over King's Landing suggests it might be
Dragon Fire that finally sets off the
Wildfire so we don't know the details
but one way or another it looks like the
Capitol will burn in Mereen we have a
second installment of Tyrion tries to
teach Musante and grey worm how to have
fun and it goes a little better than
last time did tyrion makes a comment
about sharing wine with his close
friends which makes you realize Tyrion
doesn't really have close friends he's
in a foreign city far from everyone he
knows his family mostly hates him or was
killed by him and his closest companions
back home were people he paid to hang
around him like Bron and Shae Tyrion
Lannister is really lonely the game is
interrupted when the slavers roll on in
with a big fleet it looks like Tyrians
pea steel didn't work after all at
Riverrun Jaime and Ed Muir have an
emotional talk we get a taste of ed
newest suffering in captivity these last
years and Ed Muir heavily criticizes
Jaime asking how he lives with himself
giving us an example of how most people
look down on Jaime while Brienne sees
the good in him Jaime responds by
ruthlessly threatening ed Muir saying
he'll hurl his baby son and Riverrun
with a catapult which seems to confirm
ed Muir's words that Jaime's an [ __ ]
but at the same time it succeeds in
convincing ed Murrow to give up Riverrun
peacefully so Jaime gets to keep his
oath to Catelyn
not to attack Tully's which in its own
way makes Jamie an honorable man this
shot of Jamie almost represents this
duality with his face half in shadow and
half in the light somewhere between good
and evil this is a picture of Jamie's
internal struggle but yeah the
Lannisters in the phrase take Riverrun
Brienne tries to get the blackfish to
come with her but the blackfish chooses
to go get himself killed off screen
instead which is a little lame given
that the blackfish was talked up to be
this really amazing dude and all he
ended up doing was standing around and
being grumpy but regardless spree and
heads off along the river and Jamie wave
so goodbye until their paths will meet
again in marine a siege begins with the
slavers bombarding the city the
beginning of the so-called Battle of
fire just when everything's looking
terrible Daenerys arrives on dragon back
to see where the kids have been up to
while she's been gone and she doesn't
look pleased so presumably
Dany will use her three dragons to burn
the slavers fleet though the other thing
to consider is that the Ironborn are
still on their way with their fleet so
we've got dragons and harpies and squids
all coming together in this huge crazy
battle of fire back in the Riverlands
the Hound comes across the leaders of
the Brotherhood without banners
beric Dondarrion and Thoris of mere who
are about to hang lamb and some other
brothers who apparently perpetrated the
massacre of ray's village The Hound
haggles with the Brotherhood over who
gets to do the killing and how which is
perverse and then they sit and have a
fireside chat berrak and Thoros ask the
Hound to join them offering him
Redemption and a purpose they talk about
winter and the north and it sounds like
they want to go help fight the white
walkers which is cool it's not clear how
they know about the white walkers maybe
Thoreau saw it in his flames Thoris if
you remember is a red priest like
Melisandre he's got a pretty cool
backstory himself check out the thoris
video if you can but yeah it looks like
the Hound is going north with the
Brotherhood barrack and therosis flaming
swords would suddenly be handy against
the white sand walkers maybe they'll
also get there in time for the Battle of
the bastards next episode maybe barrack
will meet John that have a lot to talk
about seeing as both of them died but
were resurrected using the power of the
red God so lots of interesting stuff to
look forward to here in Braavos
Arya wakes to find the waves killed
crane which are you should have seen
coming right
the wife gives a Bond villain bad guy
speech cause she's a rubbish assassin
which gives a time to run away
leading the way fond a chase across the
city aya lures the wave to a dark room
where she draws needle turns out the
light and kills the wave using her
skills for my time training blind which
is a pretty cool plan I adapted to
overcome an enemy's stronger than
herself
then aya takes the waves face into the
house of black and white and confronts
Jack and hugger who strangely says she
is now no one which is weird because
being no one is meant to mean giving up
your identity and personality which i
eclis hasn't done maybe Jack ins just
trying to talk his way out of being
killed him he has got a sword to his
chest though even as isleib's he smiles
for her he's clearly fond of her which
is like fine power of friendship yeah
but what's the point of being a hardened
fanatical death worshiping cultist who
gives up their very humanity if you're
just going to be cool with some kid
breaking all your rules and killing your
favorite student because you're fond of
her the men invested so much training in
aya and now that is letting her go
the faceless man of the show simply
don't make much sense which is a real
shame but regardless we've now finally
gotten to the point of the Braavos Ark
aya is now stronger and she's embracing
her identity as aya Stark of Winterfell
aya is going home but what's she going
to do there presumably she's after the
people on her list and Walder Frey seems
the obvious target he's been set up as a
bear guide this season and we've seen
him celebrating with some Lannisters in
the trailers so maybe aya will crash the
party and kill Walter we might
eventually get to see I am meeting her
family again saying Sansa and John and
coming back to Winterfell
this is big aya stark is finally coming
home
so that was a mixed episode the aya
stuff was bad in parts but there is cool
stuff happening in marine and King's
Landing and the Riverlands and next
episode is the Battle of the bastards
and after that the season finale just
two episodes are left and they both
promised to be huge so thank you for
watching and thank you to all patrons
supporting this channel on patreon
including Eric louis-dreyfus Todd Marcus
Chris Cole Erica Sierra Sean Cathcart's
and Schleifer Rajeev Kothari Caitlin
McKinney javi Ortiz VC Gillian John Nick
and bull Cheers
you